foreign
Once Upon a Time YouTubers used to pitch
products and services that they truly
used enjoyed and believed it but today
YouTubers pitch just about anything from
questionable products like skillshare
and a better help to straight up scams
like FTX Luna and nfts and it's not
surprising why the amounts that these
pontres offer is downright stupid
remember the FTX collapse well I'm a
relatively small Channel and I was
offered at 30 000 to promote some sort
of Shiba Inu bailout fund that's of
course an extreme example but I'm
regularly offered amounts of five to ten
thousand dollars from more Tim sponsors
several times at every single day given
that I post about 150 videos every year
if I did sponsors that could be an extra
750 000 to 1.5 million every single year
so it's not surprising why so many
YouTubers put their morals aside and it
starts chilling for these sponsors now
don't get me wrong here I don't hate
sponsors or YouTubers who use sponsors
in fact if it done the right way I think
sponsors can benefit the YouTubers the
sponsors and the audience
the problem is that in 99 of cases the
audience is left out of the picture in
fact the intended purpose of some
sponsorships is often for the audience
to literally get scammed but even if the
sponsor is a reputable company it's
questionable how much value the audience
is actually receiving doesn't everybody
just skip through the sponsored segments
anyway
I mean why would you watch them when
they're virtually indiscernible from
Regular Ad slots than to play before a
video the only difference is that it's
the YouTuber pitching the product as
opposed to some random actor but don't
be fooled this doesn't mean that the
YouTuber isn't any more knowledgeable or
familiar with the product than some
random actor when things go to crap like
with FTX YouTubers will be the first
ones to shift the blame to you they'll
say something like at the end of the day
it's up to the viewer to determine
whether to use a sponsored product and
that's fair but if that's how YouTubers
are gonna approach sponsors why should
you as a viewer give sponsors any more
importance than a random ad the answer
is that you shouldn't and that's
probably for the best but it wasn't
always like this at one point in time
sponsors were actually enhancing content
on YouTube and adding value to the
audience and there are still a select
number of YouTubers for whom this is
still true so here's how sponsors
devolved from being a valuable
Production Tool to being a Shameless
money grab
before we get into the bad sponsorships
let's first establish what a good
sponsorship implementation looks like
one of the best examples of sponsorships
being used well is none other than Mr
Beast for one he thoroughly vet each and
every one of his sponsors but that in
itself doesn't make a good sponsor I
mean just because you get sponsored by a
reputable company doesn't mean that it's
actually valuable to the audience now
you could go down the rabbit hole of
determining whether your audience
demographic matches the demographic of
the sponsor and what type of topics your
audience is interested in you should
also make the sponsored segment as
engaging as possible and maximize
audience retention and all of that but
there's a much simpler way to determine
it if a sponsorship implementation is
good or not the key to a good
sponsorship is that it should offer
value even to viewers who skip this
sponsorship completely but wait a minute
how could that be possible if a viewer
doesn't watch the sponsor how could they
possibly get value out of their products
or services is offered by the sponsor
well easy from the video that they're
actually watching at the end of the day
viewers are there to watch the video not
watch the sponsor so by Nature sponsors
should only be incorporated if they
directly make the production possible
this is obviously the case with Mr Beast
each and every one of his videos costs
millions of dollars to produce and even
with the 100 million views per video
there is no way he's breaking even with
just YouTube AdSense in fact he's
probably losing money even with
sponsorship money but the sponsors make
the loss much more manageable and
affordable when combined with the
Jimmy's other Ventures
in other words you can go to any of
Jimmy's videos cut out the sponsored
portion completely and you'd still
benefit from the extra production
quality that was made possible by the
sponsorship you don't have to look that
high up in the YouTube hierarchy to find
good sponsors either another Channel
with the good sponsorships is magnates
Media if you're not familiar with this
channel you should absolutely check them
out as they have extraordinary
production quality they basically
produce full-on documentaries for free
on YouTube videos like this can easily
cost several thousand dollars to produce
if not more so it's no question why they
need sponsors some other channels with
solid sponsorship Integrations are
Johnny Harris Wendover Productions
polymatter and Iraq now let me disclaim
I haven't watched every video on all of
these channels so I can't vouch for the
reputability of their sponsors but what
I can say is that for their type of
content a sponsored segment is
appropriate and it actually makes the
rest of the video better for most
sponsor videos though this isn't not the
case which leads us to bat sponsorships
a bad sponsorship is extremely easy to
spot in essence it adds nothing to the
video or the production and the niche
that's most notorious for implementing
such sponsors is the finance niche as
you all are probably aware the ad rates
on finance videos are already through
the roof they're usually able to earn 10
to 15 dollars per thousand views from
AdSense itself for larger channels this
means that they're able to earn as much
as half a million dollars per month just
from AdSense on top of this they've also
got course sales affiliate links YouTube
memberships patreon and who knows what
else so they clearly pull in an
extraordinary amount of Revenue but
that's just half the story
not only do they have a ridiculous
amount of money coming in but they have
virtually no production expenses for the
most part Finance videos consist of just
Talking Heads most of these channels can
be run by a single person and they are
often run by a single person at most
they may have an editor so no argument
can be made that the production needs
sponsors or that sponsors make the rest
of the video better in any notable way
if anything the sponsor actually makes
the rest of the video worse because the
YouTuber's thoughts have to be censored
to remain sponsor friendly in many cases
it YouTubers aren't even allowed to
mention or talk about other brands even
in passing when a video is sponsored
bigger brands are usually the worst
offenders and one of the best or I guess
worst examples of this is actually
Google if you go to a yes Theory video
called running for 24 hours to see all
of pairs you'll see that a large portion
of the video is filled with a random
blur effect on amar's arm the reason for
this was confusing it until you reach
the sponsored portion of the video it
turns out that the video was sponsored
by Google pixel and it's likely that
Amara was using an Apple Watch and an
iPhone Google's sponsorship team was
probably not super happy with this so
yes Theory had to go back and add a blur
effect throughout the entire video and
judging by the comments this very much
made the rest of the video worse some
people even went as far as claiming that
this alone made this video the worst
video they've ever produced now a
constant blur effect is no doubt
annoying but this issue becomes
exponentially worse when we're talking
about Finance content back in the day
Finance content used to be about Index
Fund investing house hacking and
maximizing credit card points but over
time more and more of the finance
Community turned to popularizing cryptos
nfts and high risk options during the
worst of it YouTubers were pitching
crypto brokerages left and right here
are some of the most notable ones that
you've probably heard of Voyager digital
Celsius block fight Genesis and FTX but
these brokerages have more in common
than just being YouTube's sponsorship
favorites all five of them are now
bankrupt I should mention that many of
these YouTubers lost money themselves
because of these brokerages but as Scott
Shaffer put it YouTubers just lost money
viewers had their lives ruined
if you thought of pitching risky
Investments weren't bad enough it gets
even worse a select number of YouTubers
have straight up turned to scamming
Their audience a great example of this
was Rubik if you're not familiar with
Ruben it's basically an online casino
and being a casino the odds are
obviously stacked against players
pitching something like this would
already be bad but it's worse than just
that you see it rubette had an affiliate
program that essentially gave
influencers five to fifteen percent of
all the money that their viewers lost by
using their platform so these
influencers were literally incentivized
to have their viewers better weigh all
of their money but at least with rubid
the viewers had the potential of making
money or at least the exhilarating
experience of playing those games with
something like Logan Paul's cryptozo
nfts viewers were basically just handing
over money to the influencer and
scammers but how did things get this bad
well of course the money is part of it
but I don't actually think that's the
main reason the main reason is because
of the classic I did it because he did
it as audiences are exposed to
sponsorships more regularly there tends
to be less scrutiny and backlash this
allows if you brush YouTubers to push
the boundaries and Pitch something
that's just a little bit more risky
instead of pitching something like a
Vanguard or Fidelity they start pitching
something like a Robin Hood or Weeble if
the audience doesn't respond poorly to
these Integrations this gives bigger
creators the confidence to start
pitching these as well and before you
know it it's normal to pitch fintech
companies but why stop there once again
a few bold YouTubers will push the
boundaries even more if stock brokerages
are okay why not Pitch crypto brokerages
and if crypto brokerages are okay why
not pitch nfts and if nfts are okay why
not just pitch scams and before you know
it you get to the situation that we're
currently in it really just comes down
to how much the audience is willing to
tolerate and put up with and some
creators like jitran are figuring out
the hardware that there is actually a
limit to what viewers will tolerate but
by the time they realize this it's
already too late
the Silver Lining about all of this is
that audiences are finally reaching a
Breaking Point and with the mainstream
collapses like FTX viewers are more wise
to sponsorships than ever before most
viewers have come to accept that
sponsors are just a part of YouTube just
like ads and that you shouldn't pay too
much attention to them this sort of
mentality is definitely for the best but
sponsorships don't have to be this way
as we discussed there is a good way to
do sponsorships that actually improve
the production and the viewing
experience and with this breaking point
being reached hopefully more YouTubers
will turn to Value adding sponsorships
moving forward and work on making the
best videos possible instead of just
turning to sponsorships that pay the
most and milk in their audiences just to
become even richer but that's just what
I think what are your thoughts on
YouTube's sponsorships comment that down
below also drop a like if you would like
to see more videos exposing YouTube
sponsors and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community suggested
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions at logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one